hey what's going on is bill bird it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday April 8th 2019 still want to say
18 2019 what's going on out of [ __ ] are
you how was your goddamn weekend you
know when people ask you a question or
there's something you do a bit about
that they just ask you a question so
they could [ __ ] say what they want to
say okay are you doing on it's good I'm
asking you how your weekends going cuz
I'm [ __ ] coming up on next week this
sad everybody thinks the big story this
week the big [ __ ] story what are they
talking about oh oh oh the [ __ ] NCAA
finals game oh baseball's underway all
the NHL playoffs are starting NBA's
right around everybody thinks those are
the big story all Trump fired somebody
else
oh it's chaos in Libya somebody [ __ ]
stepped on somebody's toe in Canada and
didn't apologize
now they've been canceled
well Canadian Twitter everybody thinks
those are the big stories those are not
alright and I'm ashamed of all you if
you think that these stories are bigger
than the fact that old freckles has gone
nineteen weeks without drinking and
coming up this weekend that's twenty
weeks to zero baby I'm I'm almost
halfway [ __ ] there Jeff the man shut
it down so there you go all you AAA
[ __ ] out there trying to say I
was one of you that I needed this whole
gang of people that helped me [ __ ]
walk out of a bar like Kellen Winslow
after that [ __ ] Miami Dolphin game I
don't need you [ __ ] people I got
control when I decide when I say it's
over
it's [ __ ] over this thing about booze
alright a booze has no respect for
[ __ ] alcoholics he sees you he sees
you weak it's like when Tyson would win
it the whole fight in the [ __ ]
stare down that's the best that bottle
of booze staring at you [ __ ] AAA
people that make I'm a tougher breed of
an alcoholic
how much known as a binge drinker it's a
switch man flip it on or flip it off
okay and I'm I'm the man touching the
socket I don't know what I'm saying I'm
just like them I'm like halfway through
I'm not trying to make fun of you
[ __ ] hey people I feel bad for any
people you know everybody gave a [ __ ]
what they thought what they had to say
and about all of their stories pre 9/11
and then after 9/11 it all went to hell
right then it was all about supporting
the troops you know the first responders
now it's all the way down to like [ __ ]
mail men and mail ladies they they're
all in front of you everybody forgot
about our fallen heroes the raging
alcoholics and all are there god damn it
right better pay that back remember that
pre [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I came to talk
anymore
pre 9/11 how many [ __ ] movies did they
make about alcoholics it's all these
[ __ ] movies all right I can't think
of any right now barfly leaving Las
Vegas oops I did it again right was not
the soundtrack Britney Spears wrote a
soundtrack to a drunk movie I figure out
what the [ __ ] it was right but there was
all these [ __ ] movies about these
alcoholics and how they couldn't do this
and they couldn't do that and they get
all [ __ ] you know and they're there I
don't know what I'm talking about people
I'm just trying to fill up an hour while
annoying a certain segment of the
population decide today I decided it was
gonna be alcoholics come on we've all
lived with one huh they're [ __ ]
excuses always blame in the bottle it's
like a 20% wasn't you the sober [ __ ] I'm
staring at right now 20% of that [ __ ]
[ __ ] wasn't you it's all in the bottle
like a little genie you just put it
right babe a bottle of booze
[ __ ] bourbon that Prince Ali fabulous
he out that movies like offensive I
think to the Middle Eastern people you
know what I mean that's a weird one
right
Hollywood thinks that were we're magical
and fly on carpets alright well I can
see you know that's not really treating
you like a human big but it's a lot
better than they treated a lot of people
in Hollywood some other groups are
treated a little bit worse anyways I
don't know why do I comment on things I
don't hey you know I just see [ __ ] and I
immediately think hey I have an opinion
I haven't read up on any thank god damn
I'm I'm having a great time right now
because we are we're on episode 9 number
9 of season four of efforts for family
and I can't tell you what's happening
but some people end up in this city that
I had to do some research on I found all
this cool [ __ ] about it you know you
know you know me all right you don't
know me you think you know me and I
think I know me but nobody else what the
[ __ ] going on with me alright but I
like you know this might surprise a lot
of you guys I am NOT a fan I can't say
I'm not a fan but I don't give a [ __ ]
about a level cities right any city that
you two tours to I don't give a [ __ ]
about it
alright at that point it's blown out
there's cheesecake factories and [ __ ]
Dick's Sporting Goods all over the
[ __ ] place it's all been devoured
paved over those giant store windows
that look like tropical fish tanks now
you know those things I like go to those
[ __ ] ones that you know the people
that are into you to have to drive from
why doesn't John Cougar Mellencamp ever
come to my city
it's not a reason why that guy always
acts like he's a farmer wasn't even like
the glee club or something he's always
acting like he's in the [ __ ] West
Side Story or some [ __ ] rain on her
scarecrow blood on the plow yeah you
[ __ ] plated ukelele stop act like you
were out there [ __ ] picking avocados
whatever the [ __ ] is you pretending you
did say that your jaw bowls should all
make a rat he was the voice of the
farmers long before all of these [ __ ]
stupid comics started becoming the voice
of [ __ ] different causes you had the
stupid musicians musicians doing it
right what I love is no matter how much
somebody when they're gonna loan their
celebrity what are you doing for this
cause famous person well I I am loaning
my celebrity I'm not gonna use it for me
in this moment in this moment I'm going
to loan it out to the common people the
people who come to my movies the people
ask for autographs the people that I
walk past at airports on my way to my
private jet
I am loaning my celebrity whenever
somebody loans their slip it's still
it's up just just being about the
celebrity isn't it you know those those
[ __ ] comedy [ __ ]
you see it those [ __ ] things right
they're always up on the stage then ever
out in the crowd with the real [ __ ]
people are they rubbin elbows with
America you know looking into the eye of
it staring at that [ __ ] post [ __ ]
now what he called Invisalign dentition
you know what you're talking about
anymore you know it's [ __ ] point you
mean you don't even know what the [ __ ]
you lookin at
god bless people who are dating right
now with Invisalign Botox hair plugs you
don't know we could be merry enough
[ __ ] troll you don't even know you
don't even realize it there should be
something you shouldn't be allowed to
fix yourself until after you find love
and you know what you're doing both
people a favor saying you know it's real
all these people in these [ __ ]
commercials late at night right I'm
laying in bed bald son of a [ __ ] top of
my head ice cold against that [ __ ]
pillow right and I'm watching the TV at
every five [ __ ] seconds they got some
[ __ ] [ __ ] coming out of a pool right
with his [ __ ] arrow waving around
he's playing [ __ ] badminton living
this active lifestyle and everybody's
always like well gee I can't [ __ ]
what I can't go for a swim unless I have
hair plugs I can't play bad man that's
not what it's about it's not about being
active it's showing that you can be
active and you're not wearing a wig and
it's not gonna come flying off that's
what used to happen back in the day
people would get a wig you know you
decided you were getting a wig and then
what you had to do was you had to leave
town okay and show up wearing your wig
and hope that they all bought it and all
of a sudden you had a little more
confidence you're talking to this
beautiful chick and everything's going
[ __ ] great right you're nervous on the
first date you feel yourself sweating
underneath you [ __ ] toupee literally
trickling down the back of your skull
going in the back of your shirt and all
you're thinking is thank God I wore a
[ __ ] sport coat all right cuz I am
sweating my [ __ ] pits off right now
you know and you fold them for a while
and then one day you don't to me
you get a little boozed up you get a
little sloppy you don't put the [ __ ]
tape on right whatever you do I don't
know how it sticks there I don't know if
it's a little [ __ ] I should look at
that up I should look that up one day
how to [ __ ] put a wig on how to glue
it to the top of your head but then then
then then all of a sudden all the
advertising I'm gonna be getting it's
gonna be like full those paint rollers
with wig glue and that now get your
second roller for free just in case you
got some alopecia down there and your
puberty we can get you can give you a
[ __ ] pube wig a two for one two for
one [ __ ] wig down there buy your
pubes it up there on top of your head
we'll even throw in some eyebrows for
you
um yeah you went to a new [ __ ] town
and then one day something happened you
had to get involved in something some
[ __ ] four-alarm fire and all they got
is one firehouse dicks they know you're
in the bucket brigade you start sweating
maybe one of the Amber's they're embers
whatever you say [ __ ] flies away from
the fire and lands on top of that toupee
and then it's like oh my god I thought
watching those people screaming from
that burning building was the most
incredible thing I was gonna see tonight
until I saw your [ __ ] wig catch on
fire pull it off your [ __ ] head and
you went from 26 to 48 right in front of
my eyes who is this outlet outsider hun
this carpetbagger
do you realize what a big deal it was
back in the day when a stranger moved to
town cuz you know there was no way to
vet anybody he didn't know what the [ __ ]
was coming to town
you know is this a serial killer is this
person wanted is this a war criminal did
this person escape from jail do they
just robbed a bank are they a
Scientologist
are they Mormon the Jehovah's Witness
who is this guy and what the [ __ ]
going on with this there's something not
right about him I can't figure out what
the [ __ ] it is and they're all gossiping
about you smiling to your face what does
he have that he killed somebody I don't
know something myself about him
something his eyes seen like there's
something in his eyes I don't know what
the [ __ ] wrong with him there's
something going on with that [ __ ] guy
then everybody starts talking and [ __ ]
next II know people are drinking we all
get [ __ ] rid of them I like this town
before he came when you get you to walk
down the street not worry about some
[ __ ] with some weird look on his
face we ought to string them up right
and then they [ __ ] go down and they
grab the [ __ ] and they write as
they put the rope around his head and
he's screaming and yelling
got a wig I got a [ __ ] wig and that
was it they took it off and all the
townspeople laughed at him and they
tarred and feathered the top of his head
they tied his [ __ ] arms behind his
back and they slapped that horse on the
ass and he was on the way to the next
[ __ ] town and that's the way it was
that's the way America was back in the
day you know and you know as difficult
as that is it is a part of our history
it is kind of funny that people used to
live a life like that and you listen to
what people complain about today and it
all pales in comparison to riding out of
town on a horse you can't [ __ ]
control with the top of your skull
tarred and feathered all right this has
been another episode well it was [ __ ]
history those [ __ ] ever listened to one
of those [ __ ] history podcasts they
tried to say that there was an entire
field of skulls and bones still existing
in Russia here you go the air II and
it's really intense [ __ ] talking and
all it took me like two [ __ ] google
searches to be like yeah that field
doesn't exist even if that wasn't true I
want the guy was so [ __ ] intense it
just annoyed me it's like why are you
taking on the intensity of this battle
as though you fought it you didn't fight
this [ __ ] thing all right so why
don't you bring your voice up a couple
of [ __ ] octaves the way you normally
talk and these people take gaming and
hey [ __ ] [ __ ] can get the Effie this
man beat this guy to death with a femur
if you're gonna beat somebody death with
with a human bone you'd think you'd want
the femur yeah I think you'd want the
femur if you could if the guy was far
enough away and you could get some sort
of extension all right other than that
uh you gotta go humerus okay it's the
second biggest bone it's an easier thing
to swing it's better you know you can
kind of also jab somebody in the face
with it
Famers a little too big for my tastes
you know ladies you might go with the
radius and an ulna you don't comment a
little nunchuck thing you can put some
chains between the two of them this is
all things we're gonna have to deal with
in well I guess 30 years with global
warming
as the world goes to hell in a [ __ ]
handbasket you know what's great about
if you don't watch the news you think
everything's fine it's a great
experiment because I've spent a lot of
time paying attention to the news
periods of my life and all I did was get
freaked out and nothing changed and
nothing got better but if you don't pay
attention and you just sit there and you
just I don't know watch sports you can't
even watch sports cuz they drag it into
that [ __ ] now every [ __ ] five seconds
somebody's dying or something and
they're bringing a troop out a [ __ ]
firefighter you know I don't for
something there's always something hey
what do you enjoy in the game well let
us remind you how lucky you are we know
how many [ __ ] times ladies and
gentlemen direct your attention to
section 203 some guy who got attacked by
a [ __ ] pack of wild [ __ ] toads or
some [ __ ] now I got to sit there and
look at this [ __ ] guy with his wart
color covered face it's one of them
stores makes you hold your kid a little
a little closer hug them a little
tighter anyways I'm gonna fly a cello
copter tomorrow
can't wait haven't done that in a minute
and uh gonna do that early in the
morning and then I'm gonna go in and I'm
gonna start working on this [ __ ]
script that's what I'm gonna do bill
how's the pull-ups coming we know you've
been your shoulders have been slowly
disintegrating and you've been trying to
build them up
I actually lat pull-downs I'm up to 120
pounds you know which is huge coming
back from rotator cuff [ __ ] injury
when you're in your 50s so all I need to
do is be able to do like three sets of
15 and then I ought to be able to try
one or two pull-ups with my own
bodyweight
that's what I've been told all right so
I got a ways to go but a little bit of
daylight there cuz I got that bet with
virzi the pride of New Jersey
all right the Newark native the the
Trenton teetotaler that I won't be able
to do 10 pull-ups when I'm 70 okay so he
sees out of his [ __ ] mind cuz I will
do [ __ ] I'll do that stem-cell [ __ ]
into my shoulders just to [ __ ] win
that bet and stem cells is basically
it's a hair transplant for your [ __ ]
shoulders right it's none how it works
it's so funny all these [ __ ] people
doing all this [ __ ] to try to live
longer you know what I mean
it's like I was trying to somebody asked
me the other day like when do you think
the perfect time to be born was and I
would say somewhere in the 1940s so you
miss out on World War two you miss out
on the Korean Conflict then he got a
Vietnam right but if you can somehow get
out of that as far as you know you got
to live in some great decades
you still got to enjoy the Four Seasons
you know things get didn't get too
[ __ ] up until like the late 60s then I
got it I got to be honest with you
though being born in the 60s and being a
kid in the 70s a teenager in the 80s and
in my 20s and my 90s out that's a pretty
good ride maybe everybody thinks that
because they're young I don't know I'm
just sick of these [ __ ] people coming
up to me who aren't scientists telling
me when the world is gonna end
it's like I get it I get it I got it
[ __ ] is [ __ ] up please for the love of
God I'm sure I have a kid all right I'm
trying to block that out cuz that's all
my god this podcast just took a dark
[ __ ] turn oh maybe I could sing you a
song um the Sun will come out tomorrow
and it'll be a little hotter than
[ __ ] yesterday and then you're done
yeah are crooked OPA Liverpool keeps
winning and so does Man City
this has been one of the most boring
things I've ever watched in sports
because knowing that these are the two
best teams and they're never gonna
[ __ ] play each other in some sort of
series to figure it out just like hey
you know I'm gonna shadow box over here
well I'm shadow boxing over here and
somehow we're fighting each other uh I I
just don't [ __ ] understand that game
no I get the game now I understand it
more I just don't understand like that's
how you decide who's the [ __ ]
champion everything else is the top two
[ __ ] people at least go out and kick
the [ __ ] out of each other and whoever's
left standing wins not in soccer not in
soccer
when [ __ ] trip and somebody makes
them roll around that you think you
literally think they're on fire but
anyways I'm still rooting for Liverpool
I'm I'm basically rooting for man not
for Liverpool to beat Man City because
they're not gonna play each other now
anymore I'm just rooting for Man City to
not win against an opponent that is a
Liverpool while Liverpool wins an
opponent that isn't Man City oh that's
exciting I can see why the world is into
this game and then I get me some hate
mail alright oh look who's here old
hiring used to be hard and it was so
much harder for a woman multiple job
sites to forget about transitioning
people they had the hardest time hiring
people multiple job sites stacks of
resumes a confusing review process but
today hiring can be easy and you only
have to go to one place to get it done
Oh [ __ ] gender neutral zip recruiter
dot-com slash bur body of the dear we go
zip recruiter send your job to over 100
of the web's leading job boards but you
know something most people would stop
there but they don't stop there nah-ha
that's it recruiter with their power
full matching technology that they must
be talking to people in ancestry.com zip
recruiters scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invites them to apply to your job as
applications coming I would have porn
sites uses as applications come in the
zip recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match and right now
my listeners can try zip or free at this
exclusive web address zip recruiter comm
/ / that zip recruited comm / / zi i p r
e CR u ITER dot-com / / zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire do you guys
like the dramatic pause like drum attic
pausing in my reading out loud maybe
read out read a little better oh look
who's here
endo cheeto indochina talked about
people who would look even better in a
suit probably homeless people you know
Christ if filthy then I gotta take a
shower you might as well dress them up a
little bit looking to get married we
have tons of options for those looking
to outfit their wedding part party guys
love the wide selection of high quality
fabrics and colors to choose from not to
mention the option to personalize the
details including your lapel lining
pockets buttons in writing your own
monogram here's how it works
visit a stylist at our showroom and have
them take your measurements personally
or measure at home yourself you cheap
[ __ ] and shop online at endo Chino comm
to choose your fabric this is how it's
written a lot of typos inside and out
choose your design and customization
submit your measurements without being
judged with your choices relax while
your suit gets professionally tailored
and mailed to you in a couple of weeks I
would love to meet the person who makes
this suit this week my listeners can get
any premium in doji no suit for just 359
bucks and indochina calm when entering
BER at checkout that's 50% off the
regular price for a made-to-measure
premium suit plus for shipping is free
that's Indochina dot-com promo code bird
for any premium suit just three Hyundai
and free shipping incredible deal for
premium made-to-measure suit once you go
custom you never go back it's ind och i
and o calm all right stamps.com not
funny wasn't watching Trump talking
about wind I know the wind I know a lot
about the wind oh you don't understand a
generator do you heat them [ __ ] all
right stamps.com
no one really has time to go to the post
no one has time to do that [ __ ] it's
just something you have to do you're
busy right even if you're not busy you
don't get up and go do that what are you
doing this weekend oh I'm going to the
post office nobody says that you know
you don't want to stand in that [ __ ]
line but you'll sit in that [ __ ]
traffic to go to the beach won't ya
who's got time for all the traffic oh
there you go parking lugging all your
mail and packages Jesus somebody needs
to drink some whole milk can't lug these
envelopes it's a real hassle
that's why you need stamps calm one of
the most popular time-saving tools for
small businesses stamps.com Briggs all
amazing service all the amazing services
of the US Postal Service right to your
computer whether you're a small office
sending invoices an online seller
shipping our products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day
stamps.com can handle it with a simply
use your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send once your mail is ready you just
hand it to your mail carrier not mailman
not mail woman not mailed gender neutral
bathroom mail carrier alright and we're
not talking about STDs or drop it in the
mailbox mailbox that's a little feminine
right how come it can't be
male uh fat like now it's that simple
with stamps.com you get five cents off
five cents off every first class stamp
and up to 40% off prioritize male
stamps.com is a no-brainer saving you
time and money it's no wonder over 700
thousand small businesses already use
stamps calm right now our listeners mind
listener my listeners get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment just go
to stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
birbee URR that stamps comm enter ber
bing bang boom just like that the
[ __ ] advertising is over hey how
about those Bruins huh you like that
playing Tampa again what what playing
Tampa Bay so smart this is what we do it
the first the beginning of the game we
come out we show them what we can do and
then once they start thinking of [ __ ] I
don't wanna meet these guys in playoffs
we just [ __ ] chill we just chill and
let them score like four five six
[ __ ] goals and now we got Tampa right
what we want him okay they've won more
goddamn games and scored more [ __ ]
points than anybody since 1995 when
these [ __ ] goddamn you know blue and
white [ __ ] from the Sunshine State
really think that they're gonna [ __ ]
skate their way to the Stanley Cup well
I Got News for you after we get done
playing patty-cake with the [ __ ]
Toronto Maple Leafs goddamn [ __ ]
asses alright we're gonna be there right
I would next round maybe two rounds yeah
but they have a [ __ ] record alright
alright and then we're gonna beat
somebody else and then we're gonna be
there alright then we're gonna do the
exact same [ __ ] thing you know and
we'll lose four games straight to you
and then your heads will not you barely
be able to get your [ __ ] helmets on
then you're gonna get the old right
there Fred from my pick in the West
having watched no hockey this year I'm
gonna pick the Nashville Predators they
got kind of close to the last few years
everyone's writing them off this year
hey why not them how about the San Jose
Sharks how about for once how about for
once they [ __ ] push through the San
Jose Sharks
don't win the [ __ ] Stanley Cup this
[ __ ] year I know Carlson's got to get
healthy why don't they just [ __ ] turn
their names to the [ __ ] dolphins
you know the porpoises every time they
score a goal
they make that little [ __ ] noise you
know they should change the logo to a
dolphin and then they in the dolphin
with its little flippers retakes that
stick back together that the [ __ ] the
shark bit in half I think that that's
half their problem it's their [ __ ]
logo is the referee see and then they
just start calling slashing because they
see a stick being broken and obviously
that's must have been what happened
right Brooklyn Nets made the playoffs
and the Houston Rockets scored 27 hit 27
three-pointers tonight none of these
teams could [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] 83
Milwaukee Bucks but you know it's a
different game Dodgers have scored a
bunch of runs there's a lot of stuff
happening I missed all of it I had
family in town family and down from Bad
welcome alright where do we go from here
no booze in nineteen weeks you know now
what a [ __ ] break up that was thank
God I'm not a [ __ ] weak alcoholic
then [ __ ] fine forty people listen my
stupid [ __ ] stories like those people
that have been sober for like 30 [ __ ]
40 years a boring of their stores at
that point is sitting there telling
drunk stories from [ __ ] back in the
day it was Eisenhower had just been
elected know was coming back from a sock
hop
buying Gold's and I went to the
whites-only fountain and I took out a
flash all right buying gold dear Billy
throwback was listening to an old
podcast where you said you were going to
buy gold because the economy was
unstable oh yeah I was a little unstable
yes ten years ago yeah I would say was a
little unstable
I'd say I had my finger on the pulse a
year after the big [ __ ] crash two
years at that point
did you ever buy gold to stash away in
case our currency crashed why would I
say that on the podcast I think some
people are treating Bitcoin in the same
way thanks and go [ __ ] yourself yeah I
thought about doing that and until I
found out how [ __ ] difficult it is to
buy gold coins it's very hard to get
your hands on some gold and then well
then I just realized you know if I have
a [ __ ] gold coin what am I gonna do
with it so say the dollar crashes and
nobody has any money and then I'm
walking down the street with a bag of
gold coins nobody has any money they
can't pay anybody and that is a guy from
the sandwich store gonna [ __ ] show up
also known as a deli is he gonna show up
at the deli and I'm gonna come walking
in as he's not getting paid and then I
have a gold coin and he's gonna give me
[ __ ] change for that somebody told me
well get some silver coins they're not
worth as much yeah I know I you know
something I don't need that [ __ ]
headache if you got gold coins what you
want to do is trade that in for some
[ __ ] cyanide pills okay and then when
everything goes to [ __ ] and people are
coming up your driveway that you know
like you're in that [ __ ] movie us
yeah you just [ __ ] you take your uh
you kill me pills I think that's the way
to do it you know get a flat-screen TV
and on all four walls of every [ __ ]
room you have just blow out the [ __ ]
ozone layer as much as you can and when
the [ __ ] goes to hell you know just
watch it on all your TVs and you know
when you recognise the helicopter
surveillance footage and you're like oh
[ __ ] that's my house so they write
outside then you take your pills or you
get a panic room you build a panic room
yeah but I think it's still smoky out I
would think there's always a way in
I think what you do I like the
underground [ __ ] I think that's the way
to go when people take you know base you
know legit things that they unload from
those [ __ ] ships down at the wharf
and then they stick him on the back of a
truck
18-wheeler chassis you know those things
from the second season of The Wire they
find all those [ __ ] pull people in
there right spoiler alert the second
season of The Wire from [ __ ] 15 years
ago I like the people they get those
things buried but the problem is the
problem is you got to dig the hole
yourself because if you hire a
contractor with the backhoe you know
sorry just yonder he's gonna be asking
all kinds of questions well you don't
hear any [ __ ] you making a lap pool
or something no I just knew you get
really ex-wife oh [ __ ] now people would
figure it out that's that's the way
that's the way you kill your wife you
know because they always say they never
they never dig lower than like six feet
maybe you watch all those Murder She
Wrote
unsolved [ __ ] that Murder She Wrote
what are those unsolved murder [ __ ]
the first 48 they're always burying
people in a shallow grave and they
always get [ __ ] caught or they just
dump it in the woods
just shoddy of all the [ __ ] times to
not dot all your i's and cross all your
T's when you dumping a [ __ ] body you
know if you just didn't kill somebody in
in a crime of passion if you're actually
premeditating the [ __ ] you dig the
hole first and go lower than [ __ ] you
know go lower than 6 feet
you got no [ __ ] dead person's alive
that we alive for a long [ __ ] time
you got all [ __ ] just go down 10 feet
ten [ __ ] feet right that's what you
do you go Cool Hand Luke times like
[ __ ] three you [ __ ] I'm going to
[ __ ] a lunatics around can you
imagine digging a [ __ ] hole for
somebody that you know you're gonna kill
you're not in the middle of digging that
all gone [ __ ] am i doing
why don't I find it another [ __ ] it's
one I just you know fight the guy when I
just let it go and I'll go have a couple
of [ __ ] beers or something like that
I'm gonna kill this person and then risk
going to jail for life and then having a
joint yeah then at that point you know
then what do you do you're a white dude
you just killed somebody now you got to
go through the pain in the ass a [ __ ]
going to the prison library and cramming
on Adolf Hitler so you can come off as a
legit Nazi and join the [ __ ] Aryan
Brotherhood and then you gotta listen to
that dumb [ __ ] every [ __ ] day for the
rest of your life you know you think in
a a meetings bad when you just a binge
drinker man wait till you [ __ ] try
that [ __ ] what just happened to my
headphones everything was good now I
can't hear myself hello hello is it
still going what happened I literally
just moved oh god don't don't do this to
me it's having such a fun time and then
all of a sudden I can't hear myself oh I
see what happened I moved in the wire
turned the volume down you guys were all
panic in there oh Christ this [ __ ]
guy with no producer he's not gonna be
able to figure it out because my [ __ ]
laptop is losing its charge enough
[ __ ] I can't move over here cuz my
headphone cord is too short you know you
wouldn't you wouldn't think that I'm ten
years into this podcast listening to
this these these [ __ ] technology
[ __ ] problems every [ __ ] person
that I started out with started doing a
podcast they [ __ ] build some Howard
Stern level studio or some version of it
you know what I mean I'm like the Native
American of [ __ ] podcasting you know
they just lived the same way essentially
at least that's what the history books
say you know they just [ __ ] this is
how you kill a deer or this is how you
use all of it all right
be you wanting these [ __ ] you know
it's [ __ ] hilarious all these [ __ ]
douche bag white people out there
[ __ ] with this stupid ideas about
minimalism acting like they came up with
that [ __ ] what the Native Americans can
the [ __ ] this [ __ ] goddamn
[ __ ] sue the [ __ ] came up with the no
I don't do this anymore
that's it right there goes to floor
number four and then that's it who the
[ __ ] came up with this stupid [ __ ]
magnet [ __ ] plug and a goddamn Apple
Computer stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] have you
ever seen the Apple building by the way
there's so many [ __ ] companies
they're just out of control
that [ __ ] looks like the Pentagon no
it doesn't builds a circle the Pentagon
is a 40 I just realize as far as shapes
goes how dumb that sounded I saw this
round building you know it looked like
to make the Pentagon
hey who went to summer school for math
almost every [ __ ] year this guy this
guy who's a [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] but up
up [ __ ] [ __ ]
stupid magnet you know meet up [ __ ]
times I've had two replug that thing and
do you understand as a person living in
a first world country that that's the
most difficult thing I have to deal with
I can't imagine the sad person that
makes this [ __ ] plug how funny is it
that they go after comedians for jokes
and all these [ __ ] you've got a damn
company stuff like sweatshop labor and
that's all fine that's all fine both we
made the computers here that cost ninety
million dollars now they wouldn't they
wouldn't if you actually paid people and
you're paid and gave them benefits and
you took it out of your end you know
they always say that well we could make
sure
here but they cost $700 each it's like
how little are you paying people to sell
these things together cuz they're not
gonna take a pay cut because they're
gonna stay in their yacht with their
mountain of cocaine and their [ __ ]
horse that's the biggest problem with
the [ __ ] world is [ __ ] will [ __ ]
anything if it has money
maybe if [ __ ] had standards all of
these [ __ ] guys wouldn't be [ __ ]
doing what I'm doing whatever it takes
doing whatever it takes to get a fine
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] that never did
anything other than suck my dick sit
next to me on my yacht with my [ __ ]
name stitched into the [ __ ] seats Oh
was there anything better than when a
yacht sinks other than the crew cuts
it's my favorite thing ever it just
doesn't happen enough it just doesn't
happen enough you know can you imagine
that you're sleeping in the bowels of
that thing like the things you had to do
to get that [ __ ] yet and all of a
sudden you start taking on water and the
radio isn't working and for the first
time in years you're thinking about a
higher power and all this sins you have
to [ __ ] confess to how fast are you
[ __ ] yammering as you start to feel
the water coming up around your [ __ ]
sheepskin [ __ ] slippers whatever the
[ __ ] rich people have everybody can have
sheepskin bill sheep see it's not
expensive all right probably some
endangered species baby seal [ __ ]
slippers would have been a better
reference whatever next podcast I'll get
it next podcast yeah so I got into
conspiracy theory and all of that type
of [ __ ] but I got into the I got into
the scary part of conspiracy theory I
was reading about [ __ ] that was actually
happening and then people's theories
about it I wasn't reading about you know
shapeshifters and [ __ ] anything the
government actually has a flying saucer
in in area 51 with a [ __ ] owl that
[ __ ] was just like I really okay
whatever I got more into the economies
and banking and you know corporate greed
and politicians and I'll whole [ __ ]
thing works and offshore accounts and
just all of this guy got into that stuff
I didn't get into late you know who were
actually aliens that were dropped by a
[ __ ] flying saucer and they're
watching us it's a big experiment I
didn't get into that the government has
time machines and the former yous gonna
come if I never gonna like [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ]
Bilderberg and stuff like that that did
fascinate me I did get into that [ __ ]
and then after a while I just became
this [ __ ] person who wouldn't stop
talking about it and I annoyed the [ __ ]
out of everybody and I had enough of a
need to be like that I said alright
alright
I'm with you guys back to the Ingrid
yeah ignorant masses I went back not
that I was informed when I was part of
the other thing I just got back to the
ignorant masses as opposed the ignorant
conspiracy theorist ignorant meaning
just uninformed not stupid all right
and went back to the ignorant masses
lazy gentle but we have someone who was
attacked by a pit bull it survived Rana
Rana Plaza
he's wearing a pink dog collar for titty
cancer all right the Golden Age of TV
sucks all right deal dear Billy tube I
know they've dubbed this the golden age
of television well they would have to
accurately call it the second golden age
of television was the first golden age I
believe was back in the 1950s and the
people called it the golden age where
the white people making the television
for other white people right but I
recent says I really hate it of course I
enjoy some of the shows that are coming
up or overall I don't enjoy the
experience I hate having to select a
show on a menu it makes it that much
easier for me to change it 15 minutes in
if I'm not impressed dude I'm with you
I'm going back to reading I like it
better I pick up a book I read a little
bit I get sleepy I go to sleep done over
over these [ __ ] streaming services
you know god bless him I know the kids
love him and I'm old and up for me I
find it overwhelming I keep saying
nobody my going you know some of these
streaming things it reminds me of Robin
Williams made this movie called Moscow
on the Hudson what's I'm sure is on
Netflix Amazon [ __ ] Apple all these
Disney lolis [ __ ] places that stream
HBO and there's a scene he defects from
Russia you know where the stereotype was
everybody had to stand in line and the
black markets are just hit the lamp here
and there weren't a lot of choices so
when he defects the first time he goes
to a supermarket and he sees all the
choices he has he gets so overwhelmed
that he faints and that's basically I
mean I don't faint but when I go on like
a streaming service thing I get
overwhelmed by the sheer amount of
choices that most of my time on the
streaming service I spend scrolling
through [ __ ] and in the end I just go
you know what [ __ ] this
it's literally like do you know like
when you got to do your taxes and for an
entire year you just threw every your
seat into this box
and there's no organization to it
whatsoever and then one day you got to
open it up and you just you don't even
know where the [ __ ] to begin that's how
I feel so I am a big believer now in
getting back I'm gonna try to get back
into reading and I walk away from my
phone now I tried for a couple hours
each day I just I just haven't you know
shut off or somewhere else
and I gotta be honest I'm not missing
anything I've never had any sort of
urgent call or anything or any
opportunity that I missed and it's kind
of nice to just sort of [ __ ] walk
away from it and then when you come up
to your phone after a couple hours is
kind of exciting because you have all
these [ __ ] text messages so you can
get right back and get a nice hit of the
crack it's kind of nice it's kind of a
nice thing
so if you've noticed a change in me as I
explore being sober I want you guys to
know that I promise you I will continue
to get more and more preachy I'm gonna
be doing I just feel like for me reading
and being conscious of a higher power
how many people have said that while
wearing like [ __ ] red-bottom shoes
that's one of my favorite characters out
here in Hollywood be caring [ __ ] he
used to be the [ __ ] with a heart of
gold now it's the caring [ __ ] you ever
heard a giving tree the sequel is the
caring [ __ ]
alright slavery in Libya I'm gonna loan
my Botox faced celebrity influencer
Instagram page to this cause because I
just feel that I just so totally just
like hey I got to tell you some of those
in a Howard Stern the other day and he
was doing this [ __ ] thing about one
of these bachelor shows and this guy had
I had never heard anybody say this I
learned this back when I was at Emerson
College vocal fry
vocal fry basically it basically occurs
when you're not pushing enough air
through your voice box and it causes you
to talk like this and it's really weird
because when people when they start to
get more intense they're still not
pushing enough air it just gets louder
and it's really [ __ ] annoying he's
wanting a fire hose and jam it down
their [ __ ] throat so anyways he was
talking about this person on the show
this guy who had vocal fry and they were
some I don't know how the [ __ ] they did
this but they started playing Lamb of
God and I love that band but they were
just playing the singer singing without
any of the instruments and just just his
vocal track I was [ __ ] dying laughing
because it fits perfectly
the band and the band is [ __ ] awesome
and I love it but when you just take
that guy out by himself like I was
[ __ ] punching the steering we always
laughing so hard so if you guys can
somehow find that Ivan well I'll do a
little search to see if it's available
to save you some [ __ ] time if you're
driving in your car here let's see here
Howard Stern Lamb of God vocal track let
me see if this comes up man it doesn't
[ __ ] you it was it was the one of the
great I don't know I'm sure somebody who
knows how to search better than me I'm
not a searcher I'm a seeker
I'm slavery in Libya dear Billy elect
have you heard about how much of a [ __ ]
show Libya is ever since Hillary Clinton
brought down Qaddafi how did she do it I
didn't know she did that and that's the
latest thing to blame her for they had a
complete breakdown in their already
suffering Society all right
they have open-air slavery oh you got a
eggwin when it goes outside you know as
long as it's inside I think you know
open-air slavery Jesus I could get
contagious and it's got so bad that the
US troops had to pull out because it
wasn't safe for them now the person gave
me a link but it was to the Washington
Post and then I got to read like half an
article and they got me interested and
then they're like hey man if you want to
read the rest of his why don't you
subscribe and only Kashia dollar big boy
so I had to go to some other site and
try to figure out what the [ __ ] going
on there he said it makes no sense that
we do this [ __ ] other than someone
powerful controls our armies to help
their business interests you know you
had such a great point to make and you
left out some word it makes words it
makes no sense that we do this [ __ ]
other than
someone powerful controls our armies to
help their business interests yeah well
Libya is saying that is [ __ ] this
saying this is just a smear campaign
which the world is so [ __ ] up right
now I would actually listen to that like
okay well now are we using this as an
excuse to invade them but it seems like
we're leaving
I don't know well are these people that
are being enslaved are they lucky enough
to be being enslaved on land that has a
lot of oil underneath it because if it
does the cavalry is coming it's just
regular earth with dirt underneath it
yeah they're in trouble yeah it's [ __ ]
up it's this well this is one of these
stories I read a little bit about it
that's why I try not to look at this
[ __ ] which I know is not what he's
supposed to do he's supposed to stay
informed and try to help fellow human
beings I don't know I gotta be honest
with you it was super depressing the
pictures and everything that I saw it
and it just makes no sense to me that I
get lucky enough to be born where I am
and how I look not saying I'm
good-looking saying I got lucky not be
born a white dude and what the [ __ ]
wrong thing that they do they were born
a different part of the world look
different nobody [ __ ] wants I mean
they're refugees I don't know it's a
[ __ ] shame and I have no idea how to
stop it
if anybody has any suggestions by the
way I'm still trying to set up a charity
for a [ __ ] local high school I can't
believe how [ __ ] difficult it is
trying to find a [ __ ] place to do it
where I can also dictate where I want
the money to go finding a high school to
do or charity yet is not that difficult
but finding one that's that that you can
actually say okay now this is just gonna
go to this right this isn't gonna go to
teachers lounge [ __ ] weed bank for
spring break
alright wife won't let me drive buddy I
got to tell you something right now
the uphill battle you're gonna have with
me through this next paragraph or [ __ ]
that I'm gonna read is trying to somehow
win back my respect
all right wife won't let you drive the
only way I respect you in this
situations if you're a [ __ ] raging
alcoholic missing at least two if not
three limps other than that I I don't
know
did you lose your balls in a farming
accident that John Cougar Mellencamp
write write a [ __ ] song about your
testes all right bill I'm in a very
strange situation my wife and I of seven
years have not been getting along very
well in the last year or so it's gotten
worse well you need to work on it dude
you gotta work on it it's hard man
marriage is work we argue all the time
mainly because she starts fighting
fights over everything she doesn't
respect me at all and she's always
comparing me to other guys she works
with
[Music]
and I was already a red flag when she
fights over everything
this sounds like misdirected I would say
topic anger she is mad at you or maybe
she's mad at herself for marrying you
and she doesn't know anyways last month
someone backed into me in a parking lot
and dented my car a bit she told me it
was my fault for not being a responsible
enough driver even though it happened
while I was 10 feet away in the already
parked car what so now when we go places
she demands to drive because I'm not a
strong enough driver this clearly this
is to clearly emasculate me I'm planning
on filing for divorce but I have to get
my affairs in order first do you have
any advice on how to deal with this in
the meantime thanks alright this is a
Hail Mary
the Hail Mary is you got a this is
possibly might have to do with the way
you conduct yourself in your business
and that's why she lost respect for you
and she wants you to [ __ ] man up so
she's pushing your buttons to see if he
got any man in you I might be wrong she
might just hey he ought to be banging
somebody work all right but the Hail
Mary here you know I don't know I think
you got to [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of him
you got to put one on her you got a dick
her down dude that's what you got to do
okay you got it you got to bring that
[ __ ] you know back from overseas dick
that's what you got it you gotta come at
her with that and if that doesn't get
her [ __ ] motor running again then I
think this is a wrap but yeah at some
point a long time ago you should have
put the foot down and been like you shut
the [ __ ] up I'm driving my own car if
you don't want you know sit in the
[ __ ] backseat deploy the airbag
before we even go if you want I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm driving go [ __ ] yourself
all right what'd you find for divorce it
doesn't seem like there's any kids or
whatever but it's just like I would just
I'd sit down and I had to ask her be
like can I ask you a question I like why
why you've [ __ ] mad at me all the time
and and I gotta be honest research stop
being stop being such a [ __ ] Jesus
Christ it's your [ __ ] car what are
you like an accountant she's like a
up-and-coming Mme and you're worried
she's gonna kick the [ __ ] out of you
then I understand that bad enough she's
driving your car you don't have to put
you in a [ __ ] triangle right a worse
spinning backfist Oh that'd be the
[ __ ] worst right by the kitchen
island you know whack your head on the
corner of it wake up covered in fruit
loops and a broken cereal bowl can't
have that
can't have that yeah that would be my
instinct I would stand up for myself and
I would you know do you remember when
that dude and that movie [ __ ] that
chick on the stairs you remember the one
I'm talking about right a history of
violence yeah you got to come with the
hit man dick he was he was coming he was
giving her the family man dick up until
then overrated
responsibilities all right overrated
underrated for the week overrated
responsibilities bill I've started
streamlining my life and I don't do and
deal with [ __ ] I don't I don't deal with
[ __ ] I want to what you guys do voice
text these things I've started streaming
my life and I don't do and deal with
[ __ ] I want to I don't even want to go
with that
do I have to fix this I started
streamlining my life I don't do [ __ ] I
don't want to I don't do or deal with
[ __ ] I don't want to I think is what
he's trying to say I recently changed
companies and have a job that is lower
on the totem pole but pays more how the
[ __ ] did you do that I used to think I
wanted to be a boss I don't good man
smart man I want to make money and have
flexible hours have have flexible hours
he wrote it twice he's so committed to
this [ __ ] your big goals bill burr keep
podcasting and find yourself a nice
rocking chair well I don't know why my
goals should [ __ ] affect you I like
how the fact that I have big goals I
don't have big goals I got a little
freckled red gulls I mean they're my
goals they're mine how dare you how I'm
living my truth keep podcasting and find
yourself a nice rocking chair dude if
you don't [ __ ] think that I'm not
trying to work towards that I've gotten
way
way way more [ __ ] busier than I ever
wanted to be ever wanted to be I wanted
to do all this [ __ ] that I'm doing but I
had no [ __ ] idea how much time it
took and now that I know that I am
stepping back I am assessing the
situation as fun as my life is this
there's nothing better than being and
all my wife or my kid my funny saying my
kids doing now right now is uh is when
she knows she's going to bed and all the
things she tries to do to extend her
time up Oh chief brush teeth you know
close the doors close the doors uh we
read a book we book oh oh oh we book oh
and then you just sit they go no honey
it's time to go to bed time to go to bed
and then she tries to cry but she's not
crying she just goes ahh
like [ __ ] Lucille Ball hilarious but
we still gave her the little Baba with
the milk in and once she sees that
that's her scotch for the night you know
anyways yeah believe me do believe me if
I could if I could figure out a way to
get off the [ __ ] wheel it's not how
it works though it's not how it works
they're not gonna have a bunch of
[ __ ] people retiring at 50
they keep well they want to keep making
money what they do is I got we're gonna
keep they keep taking a bite out of your
ass you know the only way you weren't
tired 50s if you have some disease and
you know you can be dead at 54 that's
the only way I see how to do it you know
and there's a little downsize your life
go live in a [ __ ] trailer and and
then what is it constantly come up with
new ways to [ __ ] tax people my nest
egg though they'll go after it it's
[ __ ] Lee they little these little the
Americans right now co-signing on taxing
fellow Americans 70% on [ __ ] earned
income honest [ __ ] Americans as they
look the other way on 20 trillion
dollars and untaxed evil [ __ ] non
taxpaying American [ __ ] money sitting
in the [ __ ] Cayman Islands
that's too much of a hassle they don't
want to take the [ __ ] bag all the way
to the curb they're gonna sit on the
couch and [ __ ] pick up some regular
dude off go [ __ ] yourself
anyways I don't good good for you buddy
if you can figure out how to do it if
you can figure out how to do it and I
would say one of the biggest things you
want to streamline your life is do not
have a woman in your [ __ ] life
because they cannot stop buying [ __ ]
it's it's insane it is [ __ ] insane
and whoever came up with the mall is a
[ __ ] genius because that [ __ ] is just
visual [ __ ] crack to most women just
walk and meandering around those things
anything about this does this look cute
encourage you thought you should get it
you'll feel oh my god you should totally
get that
hi guys I got [ __ ] dopes and all I do
is sit there saying that they should you
know hey ladies maybe you shouldn't earn
the same amount as a man to do the same
job when you can show yourself to be a
little more fiscally responsible what do
you want to make can you imagine if I
said this in a woman's college god I
miss doing college gigs ladies maybe you
know if you didn't [ __ ] buy something
off of Amazon every [ __ ] two days
maybe then maybe then Uncle Sam would
give you more money I don't even know if
that's even [ __ ] true that they make
less money I don't know I can tell you
right now if they got paid by the world
word they'd [ __ ] run the world
oh Jesus bill come on let's let's not -
lets not do this let's keep it happy
okay it's almost Easter isn't it
Easter Bunny's out there will be do be
do and he's hopping around like a
[ __ ] freak who wants a [ __ ]
chocolate egg do you know I never had
the balls to try a Cadbury egg
I was always confused I thought it was a
real egg I didn't understand that there
was some sort I would guess some sort of
custard alright we're gonna end this
podcast by finally finding out what the
[ __ ]
so weird they had a goddamn Cadbury eggs
what is in them I got to be the dumbest
person on the [ __ ] Internet a Cadbury
egg is a chocolate confection okay hang
on a second what is confection
confection a dish or delicacy made with
sweet ingredients oh you mean candy okay
thank you a contra cream egg is a
chocolate confection produced in the
shape of an egg all right so it's just a
dessert they have it in the shape of an
egg originating from the British
chocolatier Cadbury you make chocolate
oh excuse me boy I have a chocolate tail
the product consists of thick chocolate
shell okay here's what we need housing
the sweet white and yellow fondant
filling which okay what's fondant sounds
like it would come out of a fountain and
be a bunch of chicks dip and [ __ ] into
it fondant technologies wait a minute
fondant is the most popular cake
decoration topping it can be colored and
easily shaped the [ __ ] is what is in
fondant fondant I spelled it wrong
fondant is a type of icing no it's icing
fondant can refer to two types of sugar
based pase used in preparing decorating
cakes pastries confections I said
[ __ ] word again confection
I feel like a [ __ ] dumb arse of
sleuth right now for deserts fondant
filling which mimics the albumen what is
this is [ __ ] insane albumen I spell
that right em en not ma albumen the
white of an egg okay let's put this in
layman's term a Cadbury Creme Egg is a
chocolate dessert produced in the shape
of an egg originating from the British
chocolate guys Cadbury the product
consists of a thick chocolate shell
housing a sweet yellow icing filling
which mimics the egg yolk white now the
white egg white and yolk of a chicken
egg there now I know what the [ __ ] it is
should I do an Instagram video of me
actually eating one of those [ __ ]
things good God Almighty
who would the [ __ ] thought of that it's
kind of creative then they have the
[ __ ] and we always through me up I
always said it was a [ __ ] egg but you
know what think good you know it hats
off to those chocolate tears because you
fooled me for [ __ ] 30 years I thought
it was a [ __ ] egg alright I know
you're never gonna get those [ __ ]
four minutes back will you I apologize
I'll do a benefit for all of you okay
for for your living your truth
alright go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check in
on ya on Thursday Stanley Cup Playoffs
f1 MLB NBA playoffs MotoGP the exciting
conclusion to Premier League Soccer well
the two best teams are on a collision
course to not play each other alright
I'll see you Thursday